Welcome, welcome to the
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
Let's get to the news and jokes.
Well, guys, the election
is five days away,
and President Trump is busy
on the campaign trail.
At one of his rallies,
he tried to describe
what would happen
if Joe Biden wins.
Listen to this.
-If you vote for Biden,
it means no kids in school,
no graduations, no weddings,
no Thanksgiving,
no Christmas...
-[ Crowd booing ]
-...and no Fourth of July
together.
Other than that,
you have a wonderful life.
-Yeah. Yeah, a wonderful life.
[as George Bailey]
"Merry Christmas,
closed-down movie theaters!
Uh, w-- Merry Christmas,
boarded-up schools!
Merry Christmas,
abandoned gyms!"
[ Laughter ]
It's already a wonderful life,
except every time a bell rings,
someone gets COVID.
[ Crew groaning ]
No Christmas?
Does Trump think he's running
against Biden or the Grinch?
Later, Trump was like,
"A vote for Biden
mean no Toyotathon!
No Happy Honda Days.
No Lexus December to Remember."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
According to Trump,
electing Biden
will lead to riots
in the streets,
an economy in the tank,
and no holidays,
but, also,
he's a sleepy politician
who can't get anything done.
But this is interesting.
Today, Trump and Biden
were both campaigning
down in Tampa, Florida.
People in Tampa were like,
"Come on. We just
lost the World Series.
Now we got to deal with this?"
I'm glad both guys
were in the same place 'cause
it finally ends my uncle's
conspiracy theory that Trump
and Biden are actually
the same lizard person.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Trump went to Tampa.
And this was nice --
he brought some frozen
Nebraska supporters
so they could thaw out.
Isn't that nice?
As for Trump,
you can tell his campaign
is low on money
'cause he asked Biden
if he wanted to split an Uber
back to the airport.
In a new poll, I saw that Biden
is up 4 points in Florida.
Meanwhile, Tucker Carlson
claims that he has polls
that show Trump ahead,
but they got lost in the mail.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, the other big story
is the pandemic,
and it just came out that it's
even affecting the Space Force.
Listen to this.
-One of the highest-ranking
members of the Space Force
has tested positive
for the coronavirus.
The Vice Chief
of Space Operations,
General David D. Thompson,
diagnosed yesterday.
-Yeah. I hope he's alright.
But I think the country
will be okay.
Vice President
of the Space Force
is like being the vice
president of a darts league.
[ Laughter ]
But this is smart --
just to play it safe,
the rest of the Space Force
will be working from home
instead of their usual
strip-mall office.
[ Laughter ]
Why do I feel like
we're one day away from hearing,
"My fellow Americans,
the coronavirus is now in space.
Been one hell of a ride."
I like the way the anchor said
"Space Force."
She was almost, like,
mocking it or something, right?
-Together: Space Force!
[ Laughter ]
-Dave, could we --
Dave, can we play that
one more time
and hear that again?
-One of the highest-ranking
members of the Space Force
has tested positive...
[ Laughter ]
-Space Force!
I saw that Bed Bath & Beyond
just made a big announcement
about their famous coupons.
Take a look.
-Bed Bath & Beyond planning
to scale back these coupons
in an effort to boost profits
and be more competitive
on pricing.
Don't worry, though --
the coupons promising
15% or 20% off,
they're not going away entirely.
They just might not appear
in your mailbox quite as often.
-Ah. That's devastating
'cause now parents
will have nothing to jam
in the corner
of their kitchen counters.
Yep, in 2020,
even your junk drawer
is going through
an identity crisis.
"Without the coupons,
who...am I?"
[ Laughter ]
It's kind of sad 'cause
if Pottery Barn stops
sending catalogs,
then there will be no more mail.
[ Laughter ]
Now, this is interesting --
Harley-Davidson
just introduced something new,
and it's taking a lot of people
by surprise. Watch this.
-Harley-Davidson
has a new product.
It is an electric bike,
but look at that.
It's not an electric motorcycle.
It's an electric bicycle!
-Yeah, Moms heard that
and were like,
"Yeah, it's still a no."
"But I'm 48!"
"Yeah, no."
I'm actually looking forward
to seeing the first biker gang
that takes breaks
for matcha-tea smoothies.
Yeah, you don't look
quite as badass
in a Hell's Angels jacket
when you're riding
Peewee Herman's bike.
[as Peewee] Hah-hah!
[Giggles]
♪♪
No hands! No hands!
Hah-hah! Hmm-hmm!
[Peewee giggle]
[ Questlove laughing ]
-Wait. Stop.
[ Laughter ]
-I broke him. I broke him.
This is cool right here.
There's going to be a blue moon
on Halloween this year.
So Denny's is celebrating
by selling
a ham, egg, and cheese sandwich
with blue bread. Look at this.
[ Laughter ]
Ah, yes, the classic color
everyone associates
with Halloween -- blue.
[ Laughter ]
So, remember, even though
Halloween is basically canceled,
you can still make it
much, much worse.
But get this. Even though
some people are skipping
Halloween, sales of candy
and chocolate
are up more than 8%
compared to last year.
Yep, the only chocolate bar
that isn't selling well
is Hershey's Whatchamacovid.
[ Laughter ]
Not selling.
[ Applause ]
And, finally, you got see this.
To make trick-or-treating safer
during the pandemic,
a lot of people
have built candy cannons.
Candy cannons.
Take a look at this.
-John Downs
built this candy cannon.
He says it is designed to keep
kids safe and socially distant.
The cannon is 12 feet tall.
At the press of a button,
it uses a shop vacuum
to shoot the candy
down the tube.
-That's a weird phrase.
"To keep trick-or-treating safe,
we're introducing cannons."
[ Laughter ]
Personally,
I'll be loading gumballs
into a pitching machine.
FTOO-FTOO-FTOO-FTOO-FTOO-FTOO!
In other news, Candy Cannons
will be dancing
on the main stage tonight
at Stiletto's
in East Rutherford.
[ Laughter ]
We have a great show. Give it up
for The Roots, everybody!